hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play dead
space okay we got the awaken DLC which
is a post on epilogue epilogue to the
story of dead space 3 I've got it here
and I'm ready to go so we're gonna get
it go again on hard and I've got a
special thing to show you if it's gonna
let me because I've been playing the
game on my own and I actually beat it on
classic mode but anyway
the [ __ ] you doing man
Carver what are you doing in my
apartment we're not in your apartment
we're not supposed to be anywhere always
dead that doesn't make any sense
Isaac you activated the codex the moon
fell we fell what about the alien
machine it froze the planet it pulled a
moon out of the sky we all know that
technology can do so that's it we were
saved by [ __ ] aliens I quit trying to
make sense of it all back on the
Ishimura come on this can't be real well
what are we supposed to do now well for
starters get the hell out of here and go
where back to earth
yeah if we're dead we can do what we
want right
right
okay well that didn't answer very many
questions actually added quite a few
more questions like is any of this real
safe it's a real anyway so this game is
supposed to be a lot more poor or
oriented which I am very very excited
about like this is the only way oh yeah
oh you're actually here that's different
okay obviously I'm not playing co-op
like I was before what is this M Cait to
overclocked heavy frame okay are you
gonna ride up with me I don't have my
crazy suit on I played through all
classic mode the classic mode means you
have the same ending it's locked in on
Hard difficulty which wasn't that bad
for me but you can only use guns that
were written the original huh where are
we
things don't know they're an underground
like a steep climb okay hey I actually
did it I actually did it yay I am kind
of confused if any of this is actually
happening because that intro sequence
COEs Kondo wonky looking not very
helping with the whole not insane thing
Oh
so we did kill the moon there it is
why is the way over there
this orbit must have carried it westward
as it was pulled down by the machine I
still don't understand how we survived
any we did wide no if I was dead man
but I don't even know what dead means
anymore Irene Decker Morse is this what
they feel like after them after the
marker reanimates them could you be any
more crazy hell no we are not
Necromorphs we killed the thing that
makes them at least we don't have to put
up with that [ __ ] anymore yeah no more
moon
no more marker signal no more neck and
watch at least that's on her site yeah
now we're just stuck on this godforsaken
planet Dannic had a strong contingent
down here hunting us one of their ships
has to be around here
now that's a good idea let's get looking
dead boy that's not funny yeah it is
all right then fine shipbreaker if we
split up okay
all right buddy here bad monsters are
dead Isaac we won just call me if you
find him ha ha ha I don't think that's
how it works there buddy hello okay so
the moon is raining down all sorts of
Hell on top of our heads don't know how
power is still on man the infrastructure
they must have built is tremendously
awesome well oh okay so anyway
carbonaceous yeah just some weird [ __ ]
yeah haha okay hey don't freak out those
are the other moons like someone pointed
out on a bench use it
load up just in case yeah alright wait
my inventory is full how I don't know I
still only have a few things okay I'm
gonna get into a different suit here one
with actuals 25 slots Dead's based
Legends suit unlocked let's see
got a bunch here the n7 suit like that
one I went through the whole game with
the engineering suit is a nice throwback
but I'm not gonna go back into it again
where is my where's my advanced suit I
had an advanced suit unlocked oh well
I'll go with n7 just cuz I I played
through Mass Effect's DLC just again and
it was great DLC hopefully that means
that this is gonna be good deal season
well I'm just very excited because I
love these stories I love space stories
space stories are my favorite I
absolutely love imagining a whole
different world out there that we could
like just tons of stuff to explore and
so we're kind of just mish mashing up a
couple different things here
anyway I should still be upgraded we yep
I still got all my old upgrades not so
much on the Kinesis but I got tons of
supplies so let's go ahead and slam that
up a bit don't know why I would need
rains but here we go
I got so much tungsten and materials
that I'm not even worried about spending
them okay now let's see if my little
thingy is here
three speed circuit set preload clip
haha yeah yeah it is it's here it's here
it's here
I like it I wanted ha ha ha ha
I don't even I wouldn't ever need to
upgrade it why am I even doing that it's
it's not the type of weapon that you
need to upgrade wow that's a lot of
stuff
jeez okay Wow all right then I did not
know that I had that many where did it
get all these from I did not have this
many I don't know where these came from
maybe because I beat the game twice or
something like that like I literally
just beat the game so that I could get
this check it out yo this is the
greatest weapon ever and little I got to
play with this roof a little bit
everybody free bang bang bang
yeah Oh that'll make a great screen shot
hello
okay alright enough silliness there's
supposed to be a more serious and scary
DLC so I'm not gonna use that look how
much it's infinite ammo so basically
whoa
where hey there Norton how you doing
going crazy good oh hey Wow woo love you
Jesus Christ whoa hang on I'm gonna show
this Friday Jesus that Norton one look
freaky as hell bang bang bang bang hi
ah where'd you go man that Norton
Necromorphs was weird-looking i
thurgood's cuz it still had a human face
this kid how can there still be
Necromorphs does it matter
yes it matters either we're actually
crazy we didn't stop the waters uh-huh
Oh God
oh we have to get back we have to Warner
we need a ship keep walking okay all
right so things are going to hell I'm
not gonna use their hand as cool as it
is it kind of takes away from the tear
roar although hopefully the tyvan I was
a victim there it is
although hopefully the terror is not
oriented with weapons so it won't even
matter I just love that thing I mean a
apparently bad sort of weapon was in
Dead Space 2 if you beat it on
impossible mode and then if I beat this
on impossible mode i unlock retro mode
which I meant if I managed to do that
I'll show you guys
who's uh who's coming
oh that's not good this is not good we
are all away now we can hungry
but where is it take us home
Isaac make us no okay
I thought Isaac was over the crazy parts
but apparently he is not ought you
little guys again you guys are the
little demons inside of Isaac's mind I
remember you in Dead Space 2 suck some
automatic weapons Oh cousin nothing
compared to him hi dad get back okay
shotgun does not do too well
but a machine-gun sure does hey anybody
the other moons they're awake what this
moon must've contacted the others before
we could kill it oh then we really have
to get to earth and warn everyone
yeah I think they know where earth is
good then let's hurry the [ __ ] up and
find a shift um don't you aren't you
worried about leading them to earth
that's bad that's bad yo
man giant living space alien moons not
good ah-ha-ha-ha good hello son of a
[ __ ] I don't like you
haha suck it down ah that's another one
that's hardly fair
there we go good thing I got all these
damaged modules hi
okay I thought nothing is bobbing up
behind me
all right then thank you thank you
magical space moon
oh okay this looks bad am I going this
way okay let's just move forward try to
get to some semblance of safety hey
these things are back except they're not
little kids anymore I wonder when
there's you gotta be yeah these are from
dead space too but they seem to have
changed all the monsters and represented
little kids and babies I don't blame him
for that although it was a bit more
morbid when you had to shoot up a whole
bunch incomplete children basically I
mean they were mutated aliens but they
looked like children so there was that
kind of whole morbid sense of morality
effing up lots of items so thank you
thank you thank you little guys thank
you for your contribution to the Isaac
Clark is a badass society
all right hahaha okay I might actually
try bit more with my little old devil's
homes yeah I probably won't resist the
temptation huh huh voice has spoken to
me
yeah to earth no thank you
we gotta find one of their ships before
they're all gone let's gather the Sun
closeby maybe if we weren't split up
we'd be able to get there faster but
whatever I don't have any friends to
play dead space co-op with this is some
pretty impressive DLC so far I mean
there's a lot of stuff to it from what I
can tell I mean they put new monsters in
hi buddy ah screw this fine fine
I earned this I deserve to use it
son of a [ __ ] when I get to the actual
scary part which I imagine is on the
ship I'll put it away but for now you
guys get to see it in action and it is
awesome hey hey ha ha ha [ __ ] Oh mugs
bang bang Banga Banga Banga ok alright
enough of that
yeah okay all right so
I know and away
I need you
ah [ __ ] do you see them they're kicking
off there's not gonna be any left head
towards the ships
hurry hurry yeah hurry we're not gonna
make it yeah hi
I'm gonna leave the crazy ones alone you
know that's what I was always wondering
when I was playing through it again like
how does
okay that's something how does this no
no you don't you sons-of-bitches I do
not like you you [ __ ] off I can't see
anything all rap hi I see you there
get away I got a dangerous deadly weapon
here yo I measured me Isaac Clark got
the devil horns what would that who's
that you will give you the baby whoa
they look different - did they change up
some models for this one these look a
lot more vicious
but seriously look at this they're
beefier that is weird and they got like
mount like big horns on their mouths -
with and I already checked I can't use
the devil horns on impossible load
bang a
duh you don't want to mess with me I
used to be a badass before
yeah where are you running off to I see
you I want you hey let me get you I see
you there we go I can't pick it up like
I need any more upgrade circuits damn
look at my inventory really kind of
shaky out here real reload to clip like
I need it hi I'm rocking out for a
second
it's gonna be really hard not to use
this thing when I move forward in the
story like when I get to the ship which
I'm assuming is where all the scariness
is when I get to the ship
I want to give it up
I don't wanna but Phil wanna I don't
wanna it's mine
crap there goes another one we're gonna
get stranded down here it was closer
there might be more nearby there's gotta
be at least one more that would be a
sucky way to end the DLC I had y'all
right there Isaac y'all right there
buddy
you don't look too good can anyone hear
me my co-pilot just threw himself into
the engine and gromit turbine to a halt
uh uh everyone is losing their minds I
can see other ships ticking
Oh in the command center courtyard why
did he have to scream like that before
he blew his head off
that was weird okay all right I'm
putting the gun away I'm not even gonna
have it in my inventory because if I if
I do I'll just use it constantly and I I
don't want that to happen so back to
Hammonds grenade launcher because I
think that it's about to get a little
weird Oh were you waiting for me to turn
ok I remember this place yeah ok this
one why didn't I find this text long
before when the sky had cleared we gazed
upon our fallen sides heavenly body loom
tall where I met the horizon looking
more like a cracked egg than the bringer
of unity what see ya oh this is one of
this is a message from one of these guys
alright buddy
anyway what I was wondering before I
don't think I actually mentioned it um
how if those things are organic in some
way they have to eat they do they just
they gotta so I was wondering how you
would possibly possibly have enough food
to feed a frickin moon like how would
that even happen I don't even know no
that is the grenade launcher thank you
kliklak label Emma yeah sure
oh yeah they are yeah there are they are
coming
did you just want to make that noise for
no particular reason or did something
actually happen coffee it's not just us
everyone is going insane oh good any
ships yet yeah can you get to the
vehicle depot one of the command sir
yeah I'm almost there now hey Ian
there's a chef yay
up here hey man you're quick buddy all
right I'm coming bro ham yeah listen I
always thought that their interaction
started late come on are you real are
you real or fake
what are you what the hell are you
what are you things
what I was just being a cache you've
been standing there doing nothing I said
the ship needs fuel
hit the switch on the big tank down
there okay yeah yeah I just getting
plenty of crazies use apparently he's
been the only one that's been resistant
to this I'm actually surprised that he's
been able to hold his cool for so long
because Dead Space 2 is just a wild ride
of insanity
I mean Dead Space 1 you got to see it
slowly progress up high I knew you were
fake you [ __ ] [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
get away from me
I'm not crying I you're all crazy for
digging upgrade duh Isaac card not crazy
there's a car driven titania tiny
hi that's on me Carver do you not see
this [ __ ] and they do look different
there's even little baby ones that I'm
dying here Carver I wonder if like
Carver was actually down here fighting
with me would it it drop it actually
dropped an item
Jara Carver was like if I was actually
doing call woodcarver be going crazy
with me right now car are you're not
helping me bro that's why they killed
himself because I got killed by their
vision I'm talking about the other guys
in there oh hey Carver buddy thanks for
the assist
gah here it's just a little
oh no oh no what now the shock drive on
this thing is out it's only got impulse
so we're stuck just stuck on this star
system we can make it as far as Pattillo
we'll just have to find something up
there to play with
we'll make it home don't worry worry I
don't know if I'm dead or alive what's
the word
let's pull in here
Tara know why I'm reading one of
Unitologist transponders it's coming
from the cradle what happened to the
other ships one up in the minefield I
guess keep scanning for ships that are
intact
I'm gonna have a look at this one okay
looks pretty messed up yeah no kidding
it's been gutted got it what the hell
for
and we did so good on to the Terra Nova
I'm gonna head in why okay you you check
the bridge I'll poke around an
engineering wait why why would that be
the correct order
Carver seems to constantly forget that
he's with the universe's greatest
engineer right here just like Gordon
Freeman is the universe's greatest
theoretical physicist button thrower
switch flipper and also alien fighter so
is Isaac okay so anyway need me sum up
what's that I hear
ha bling-bling so this is just getting
interesting I'm pretty sure this is this
ship is where this whole DAC is supposed
to start I'm actually quite impressed
because there are new monsters I mean
their reason reusing some of the old
levels that's okay they can't be
expected to create a whole new level use
what you got if the story fits why not
if anyone out there is still saying no
you have to finish the plan no we could
use this shitty reactor to power a shot
point drive okay taking it to the
conning tower at mid-station and locks
me out if you can get to the bridge
there should be a way to defeat the
lockdown but you'll need to well time
for you to join the church brother
I screaming with a little weird do that
yeah yeah you think you can lift the
lockdown I'm about to find out duh I'm
Isaac Clark course I can lift the
lockdown who do you think I am so -
always I was at the conning tower for my
optional mission so that should already
be nice and cleared out for me
hopefully I don't know I know these
things stop looking at me like that
okay oh it looks nice contrast yeah okay
who's talking who's whispering this must
have been a want what it must have been
a like on the issue Mora just as people
were going insane I actually probably
accelerated even because it's like
hey shine Oh weirdos I didn't sound very
human
are they Necromorphs are they just crazy
people I can't rightly tell okay alright
I'm just about out of time we read this
first thought diary with the voice came
a wave of UNAC controlable expressions
of faith huh when I'm bored vowed in the
group chose to meet the voice sooner
rather than later and scattered his
brains on the ceiling
hahahaha Wow
faith has given way to madness in a new
church is forming my only hope is to get
this ship functioning so we can return
to Earth before we are all taken by
these new distractions okay so yeah the
craziness has reached a whole new level
so anyway so I'm all out of time for
this one things are about to get a
little bit weird here so thank you all
so much washing click the annotation for
more videos and I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye
thank you
Moctar
love
Oh